Afghan women's rights to education to
University to work and to fulfill their
dreams
all of this was the focus of talks
between the United Nations and the
Taliban in Kabul this week
on her return un deputy chief Amina
Muhammad told Al Jazeera she was there
to amplify women's voices the women are
getting trodden on they need to breathe
they need to come back they need to have
their rights and protected and given
back to them where they've been taken
away it is incredibly important
last month the Taliban banned women from
attending University they've also been
barred from secondary education and some
government jobs
the Taliban says it's looking for
Solutions but also wants to discuss
International sanctions
there was uh schools open there was
universities open there have been again
suspended and we are working on finding
a permanent solutions that this economic
situation was precipitated by the
20-year occupation and it has been
exacerbated by the reimposition of
sanctions by by asset freezers and by
restrictions on banking when the Taliban
took power in August 2021 the U.S froze
9.5 billion dollars in the Afghan
Central bank's money that was held in
the U.S it later announced a transfer of
3.5 billion dollars of that money to a
fund it says will help Afghanistan's
economy but the money won't be managed
directly by the Afghan government
continuing sanctions means Afghanistan's
banking system remains largely cut off
from the rest of the world meanwhile the
UN says nine of ten households aren't
getting enough to eat some analysts say
even if sanctions are eased it's
unlikely policies on women are going to
change the underlying foundational
principle of that Islamic Emirate is
that the Emir Sheikh hibertullah has
unchallenged authority to pass any
decree which he likes as a Muslim U.N
deputy chief Amina Muhammad says she
hopes to convince the Taliban otherwise
ikra the first word in the Quran we're
talking about knowledge seeking light
but I don't see anywhere that that says
you know we don't have a right to
education
the UN says it will continue to push for
Progress so women in Afghanistan are not
excluded from public life
Laura Khan Al Jazeera